Oh
everyone and thank you for joining
for part one of our three-part amino
oncology series today's live broadcast
deciphering the cancer immunity cycle
through next-generation sequencing is
presented by dr. Simon Colley head of
software and bioinformatics for the i''m
Taurus next-generation sequencing
platform I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I'd like
to now introduce our presenter dr. Simon
Colley dr. Simon Colley is a head of
software and bioinformatics for the Ion
Torrent
next-generation sequencing platform as
part of the clinical sequencing division
of thermo Fisher Scientific his team is
responsible for the full bioinformatics
workflow from acquisition and processing
of raw data off to semiconductor chips
to delivery of downstream analytics of
biological insights prior to working
with the Ion Torrent platform
dr. collie spent 10 years at Affymetrix
as head of algorithms and data analysis
for expression genotyping and other
applications
dr. collie has a PhD in statistics from
the University of California Berkeley
and a BA in mathematics from Trinity
College Dublin for a complete biography
on our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr. collie you may now begin your
presentation thanks very much for the
introduction and I'd like to thank all
of the audience for joining us today and
giving me the opportunity to discuss
with you some of the solutions that we
Thermo Fisher Scientific have been
developing for research into the immuno
oncology space
so we believe is a huge opportunity for
the application of next-generation
sequencing to immuno oncology that it's
going to open the doors
further characterizing the complexities
of immune oncology including tumor
microenvironment and biomarkers that
might exist there improved biomarkers
have the potential to predict who will
respond to immune therapy bleeding in
turns more effective patient selection
strategies and more successful outcomes
of immuno oncology trials new biomarkers
may also have the ability to predict
predisposition to adverse events which
will enable people who are candidates
for immune oncology therapy to make
knowing decisions about their risks
should they elect to go ahead with
checkpoint inhibitor therapy furthermore
due to their high accuracy and
sensitivity next generation sequencing
assays can also help in researching
areas beyond the checkpoint blockade we
expect t cell receptor sequencing to
help accelerate development and improve
effectiveness for approaches such as
chimeric antigen receptor t cell
therapies and cancer vaccines
you
the Cancer immunity cycle is very
complex and it needs to be studied from
multiple angles the figure shown here
it's from a 2013 cell publication by
Chen and Melman and it provides an
overview of the cancer immunity cycle it
begins in the lower left with the
release of cancer cell antigens into the
tumor microenvironment upon cancer cell
death those antigens get taken up by
antigen presenting cells they're both
the lymph node party cells are primed
and activated the activated t-cells are
released to the bloodstream and their
traffic to the tumor where they
infiltrate the tumor and they recognize
the cancer cells leading to cell death
and restarting the cycle again there's
multiple elements in the cycle here that
can be monitored to characterize tumor
immune interactions
these include sequencing of t-cell
receptors to profile the status of the
immune repertoire they include studying
the immune response within the tumor
microenvironment itself by a
characterization of RNA expression and
they include the molecular profiling of
the cancer cells within the tumor
microenvironment look for driver
mutations and other biomarkers such as
tumor mutation burden tumor munion
interactions are very complex and does
not one perfect biomarker for predicting
different events of interest and we
believe that the best approach is going
to require multi-dimensional views of
the data where multiple biomarkers are
considered together
to address the needs we've developed an
extensive portfolio of next-generation
sequencing based solutions to enable
these kinds of multi-dimensional
approaches to research in the counselor
mmunity cycle some of the products I
will be speaking about today include the
on combine T cell receptor beta long
read assay or LR si the TCR beta SR or
short read assay the immune response
research essay and the tumor mutation
load assay
you
I'll go into more detail on those four
solutions in the remainder of the
presentation but before doing so I just
wanted to show first how they fit within
our broader and continually growing
oncology portfolio we break down our
solutions into four different categories
we have a range of solutions for solid
tumor research so FFP optimized
solutions including both focused panels
cancer specific panels and comprehensive
panels weave ranges solutions for liquid
biopsy applications so for the study of
cell free DNA in blood again we have a
mix there of panels that are specific to
certain cancer types and earlier this
year we launched a pan-cancer cell for
Yas a then we have the immuno oncology
solutions that I'll be speaking to in
the rest of this presentation and lastly
we have panels focus on the study of
heme oncology our myeloid research essay
and our childhood cancer research assay
there are some distinct advantages
associated with the way that we
configure our next generation solutions
next generation sequencing solutions all
the solutions that I'm showing here
they're supported on our automated Iron
Chef and gene studio s5 systems they've
all very limited hands-on time and I
degree of automation which makes for
very fast and highly reproducible
workflows the systems are easy to deploy
and easy to validate and that saves time
and money relative to considering
alternate approaches that may involve
the use of multiple different systems we
also offer pre-configured and integrated
bioinformatics analysis for these
solutions and that gets you all the way
through your workflow to meaningful
answers for your applications making it
accessible for people who aren't
necessarily bioinformatics experts to
enable them to get to the answer that
they need but also for the people who
are by informatics experts we make it
easy to get into the raw data and to
pursue different kinds of analyses or
use of different third-party tools for
people who want to do that and lastly
all the solutions that I'm talking about
here today are based on the ion ampliseq
technology and so they come with all the
advantages mentioned above as well as
providing high sensitivity very low
error rate and one of the fastest next
generation sequencing workflows
available
you
so I'll move on now to discuss the first
of the forum you know and ecology assays
that I'll be talking about today
the on combine T cell receptor beta long
read si or LR si
our beta L RSA it's a unique solution
for profiling t-cell receptor beta
immune repertoires in humans about 95%
of the T cells carry alpha beta
receptors and among these the beta chain
is the most informative the remaining 5%
of the t-cell population has Gamma Delta
receptors which aren't the subject of
discussion here today the assay is
unique in that it uses the established
ampliseq technology to capture the
complementarity determining region or
CDR 1 2 & 3 of the t-cell receptor beta
vdj rearrangements in cDNA so like some
other immune repertoire assays the on
combine TCR beta long read assay uses
the highly diverse CBR 3 region TCR beta
rearrangements to identify the t-cell
clone and to measure common repertoire
metrics like richness clonality
diversity and so on but in addition we
found that the use of our long read
sequencing and the study of the CDR one
and two regions provides valuable extra
information
so unlike the CDR 3 region CTR 1 and 2
are not the product of somatic
recombination rather they are germline
in origin and they can be used to
investigate predisposition to adverse
events to a particular immunotherapy as
allelic variants in CDR 1 & 2 can alter
interactions with HLA like all the ion
ampliseq based assays this assay has
very low and flexible input requirements
it can go down to as low as 1 nano gram
of input
you
so
the TCR beta assay can also be viewed as
another kind of solution for liquid
biopsies the term liquid biopsy
typically refers to the analysis of
tumor cells or their products from
peripheral fluids such as blood or urine
and today the most common liquid biopsy
application has been the study of cell
free DNA in peripheral blood the diagram
on the right highlights the results of
centrifugation of peripheral blood this
separates the sample into plasma buffy
coat and erythrocytes plasma can be used
for cell free DNA sequencing
while the buffy coat fraction containing
peripheral blood leukocytes or PBL's can
be used for t-cell receptor beta
sequencing this buffy coat is often
unutilized in many lab workflows and it
presents a valuable additional source of
liquid biopsy information that in many
situations is just discarded tumor
specific T cells are primed by tumor
antigens and lymph nodes and enter into
the peripheral blood before infiltrating
the tumor which is why this is a sample
of that great interest for studying
tumors so one can measure T cell
responses to the tumor by sequencing
PBL's
and that can provide predicted
predictive information regarding immune
mediated adverse events and responses to
immunotherapy
so I'll move on now to discuss a related
essay the TCR beta short read or SRS a
so like the long read hace the short
read hace enables characterization of
t-cell receptors using a short amplicon
strategy that probes the CDR 3 region
exclusively the use of short amplicons
enables the use of the panel with FFPE
samples whose RNA and DNA are typically
degraded to varying degrees and the
ability to work with degraded FFPE
samples makes this panel ideal for
studying the immune repertoire in the
tumor microenvironment
as with the long read hace it's got
flexible input requirements and it comes
with pre-configured optimized by
informatics capabilities
one of the primary application areas for
the TCR beta short read assay is the
study of the tumor microenvironment
which contains cell types that can
contribute to immune evasion by
inhibiting anti-tumor response of
effector cells these cell types include
effector cells which are short-lived
activated cells that defend the body in
an immune response it also includes
immunosuppressive cell types such as
regulatory T cells or T regs myeloid
derived suppressor cells and tumor
associated macrophages the T cells in
the tumor microenvironment can be
studied with the TCR beta short read
hace some of the other cell types can be
characterized by the immune response
assay which I'll be describing in a
little bit I'd like to add some comments
here also on the use of RNAi versus DNA
as input to the short read a say since
the SI is compatible with both types of
input where FFP sample quality permits
if the DNA isn't too degraded and the
RNA isn't too degraded we believe that
working with RNAi has some advantages
one advantage is that for the same total
input mass use of RNA rather than DNA
will typically yield a better and
broader representation of the underlying
repertoire because to begin with the
source material is itself more targeted
another advantage of using RNA as input
is that analysis time we can make the
assumption that the reads are coming
from full-length productive RNA
sequences so in other words
mathematically we can assume that the
length of all of the sequence sequences
should be a multiple of three and that
allows us to perform some informatics
based error Corrections to achieve
extremely high accuracies when using RNA
as input in situations where the RNA
from FFP is too degraded DNA may end up
being more effective so it's something
that people may wish to consider
possibly try both approaches and see
which one works best
you
so the assay works well across a broad
range of t-cell contents the examples
are shown on top here are from tonsil
FFP RNA and DNA on the left and the
right and both of these samples have
relatively rich and relatively even
repertoires the figures shown here the
histograms are showing the distribution
of the read lengths and the darker
figures I'll be explaining their spectra
typing plots I'll explain those in a
little more detail in a few slides on on
the bottom are two examples that have
low t-cell content so on the left is a
lung FFP DNA sample it has just under a
hundred clones detected within it and
you can note the more quantized
histogram of the read lengths due to the
lower diversity in the repertoire and on
the right is an example from cell free
DNA now with the use of cell free DNA
it's that there is relatively little
target amplify ball material in a sample
type and so we do tend to get a larger
number of off target reads
which is what is causing some of that
larger peak to the right in the in the
read length histogram
you
so the young combined TCR beta short
read hace can also be used for research
in the detection of post remission
recurrence of t-cell malignancies so in
situations where malignant clones have
been characterised up front by
repertoire profiling pretreatment then
post remission use of this assay can
lead to the analysis of samples to look
for recurrence of those malignant clones
and for this kind of application we
focused on configuring the solution so
that it can achieve very sensitive
limits of detection and we've
demonstrated down to being able to
detect one in a hundred thousand clones
so to go into a little more detail on
that minimal or sometimes measurable
residual disease refers to situations
where a small number of malignant cells
can remain after treatment possibly
leading to future recurrence an example
of this would be t-cell non-hodgkins
lymphoma in which the sample type is
going to be either peripheral blood or
bone marrow and despite the fact that
DNA quality will typically be good in
this sample type we do recommend use of
the short read assay with DNA as input
as it's going to enable the assay to be
more quantitative which is which is what
we want in this kind of application it's
critical to appropriately set the amount
of input DNA being used and to set the
total number of sequencing reads to
achieve at the desired limit of
detection
the typical limit of detection that is
often targeted would be in the range of
1 in 10,000 which is often associated
with higher risk of relapse or one in a
hundred thousands which is often
associated with much lower liske risks
of relapse the lower limit of detection
can require as much as a microgram of
input and can require multiple
sequencing replicates extreme
sensitivity is required for this
application so when we've released the
short read assay earlier this year we
released it with support for the use of
dual barcodes with the samples and this
avoids problems with barcode
contamination sometimes also called
index hopping which would be otherwise
very detrimental to this kind of
application
so I'll move on now to discuss the
bioinformatics solutions that we have in
place in our software package ion
reporter that we use for the analysis of
TCR beta assays so at a high level the
workflow consists of the standard
primary analysis and base calling that
we do for all of our applications we
eliminate low-quality and off target
reads from further analysis and the
reads that we take through the first
thing that we do with those in the case
of having used RNA as input is we align
them and we do some correction for in
del sequencing errors and this is where
we leverage the property that I
mentioned previously where we're able to
use the the fact that we have productive
RNAs being sequenced and their length
should be equal to a multiple of three
we're able to use that fact to identify
where there are likely sequencing errors
and correct those and the reason we can
do this is because the primary error
mode of the Ion Torrent system is to
have insertions and deletions and in
this case that's quite fortunate because
those are readily identifiable as having
as being present because they cause the
length of the sequence to change and so
we're able to analyze the alignment and
our knowledge of where our errors are
likely to occur in the sequence to
correct those errors as a result of
getting in the case of sequencing RNA in
particular getting especially high
accuracy on the underlying reads the
next step applies to the remaining steps
apply to both DNA and RNA is input where
we do a step of eliminating errors that
are induced during PCR in the library
prep itself where we identify if there
are some clones present at very low
frequency that are a very short added
distance away from a very high frequency
clone and in those situations it is much
more likely that there has been a piece
Arar during the library step to create
this very low-frequency clone closely
related to a very high frequency clone
as opposed to that actually being a real
event then lastly we report out the
clone types and we have some secondary
analysis exploratory features that I'll
describe in the subsequent slides
so this slide shows a few of the
different data views that we provide the
one on the top left the specs type in
plot this is an interactive plot that's
available in ion reporter that captures
broad information about the repertoire
the x-axis here shows the different V
genes stratified by their location on
the genome and the y-axis shows the CDR
3 lengths the size of the points plotted
there is proportional to the number of
clones and the points can be colored
according to a variety of different
metrics of possible interest including
mutation rate evenness Shannon diversity
and so on in the particular example
that's being shown here at the moment
it's showing the evenness and so you can
see for example towards the left a
larger white dot that corresponds to one
particular V gene associated with a
longer CDR 3 length in which there is a
large number of clones and you can tell
because of the very low evenness or the
white color that that is predominantly
driven by a 1 or a small number of
clones really taking over and having
been expanded
the plot on the top right is another way
of summarizing the repertoire this is
showing the variable gene usage so the
x-axis here are the different V genes
and the y-axis shows the number of reads
associated with each V gene in the plot
on the top its coloring the different
bars there according to the variable
gene allele so this enables you to see
the different allele usage this is
enabled by sequencing the CTR one and
two regions the plot below that the
lower right is showing the same data on
V gene usage except this time instead of
coloring by V gene alleles its coloring
the data according to the the clone so
for example you can see in one of the
the tallest bar near the left there is a
single in the magenta color a single
very large expanded clone then in the
orange color there is a second clone but
is also fairly expanded and then a
series of lowly abundant clones in gray
at the top of that bar
there's another couple examples of plots
that we provide to help explore the
repertoire so the one shown here at the
top left is showing the combination
frequency between the V jeans and the J
jeans so again the V jeans are in the
x-axis the J jeans are on the y axis and
the different colors shown here
correspond to the frequencies in which
those are found in the reads and so the
blue there are corresponds to the lowest
frequency so you can see that there are
some V jeans that are essentially unused
and then varying degrees of usage of
different V and J gene combinations and
then lastly we also provide a table of
all of the tonal types so it shows it
shows on each row each clone with its
variable and joining gene the amino acid
sequence of the CDR 3 and the underlying
nucleotides that comprise that amino
acid sequence along with the count and
frequency and there can be benefits to
looking not only at the amino acid
sequence but also at the nucleotides
because you can look for interesting
phenomena like convergence where you see
multiple Colonna types with the same
amino acid sequence but different
underlying nucleotide sequences and
phenomena like that will be the subject
of one of our future discussions in this
series
so I'd like to move on now to talk about
our on command immune response research
assay so this is another assay that's
intended for study of the tumor
microenvironment
so this panel is a targeted RNA
expression panel focused on just under
400 genes when we design this panel we
wanted to make it sufficiently broad to
capture the composition of the tumor
microenvironment while at the same time
keeping it sufficiently focused to
enable high sensitivity so in line with
these goals we created this the content
for this by carefully curating multiple
sources so including over 200 relevant
peer-reviewed publications we took
suggestions from key opinion leaders in
the field we used public databases such
as David for pathway annotation clinical
trials.gov
for drug targets and the online database
for Co expressing genes as well as
taking direct feedback from a number of
drug developers on what they thought
would be important content for this
panel the content of the panel can be
broadly grouped into a few different
categories shown in in the middle of the
slide there these include things like
drug targets and genes involved in
checkpoint pathways markers of different
type of immune cells and signaling
molecules that inform B and T cell
activation tumor characteristics such as
tumor antigens proliferation apoptosis
and lastly we've included some
housekeeping genes to provide sample run
quality control and to use for
normalization and the the key
applications of interest for this panel
are use in studies of mechanism of
action discovery of novel biomarkers and
in providing rationales for drug
combination
so the fact that the panel is very
targeted on just under 400 genes is key
enabling enabling it to be extremely
sensitive so unlike whole transcriptome
approaches there's very little
sequencing throughput that ends up
getting wasted on uninteresting highly
expressed genes and as such it can
capture genes such as interferon gamma
with very good sensitivity even though
that gene is typically expressed very
low levels the data shown in the plot
here is comparing the immune response
research assay with a whole transcript
the whole transcriptome panel on a
subset of overlapping genes between the
two of key relevance for immune response
and as expected because of the very
targeted nature of this expression panel
the expression levels that we're
detecting in terms of read per million
for the immune response essay are
predominantly higher
so lastly I'd like to move on to
describe the tumor mutation load si this
is another si focused on the tumor
microenvironment this time for
characterizing the cancer cells within
the tumor microenvironment
you
so trimmer mutation burden it has
emerged in recent years as a biomarker
of key interest
it's basically an assessment of the
number of somatic mutations presence in
a tumor genome often measured or
reported as the number of mutations in
coding regions sometimes also
specifically focusing on nonsynonymous
mutations in the coding regions of a
tumor genome and the reason why this is
of key interest is that in tumors that
have high somatic mutation loads they
are more likely to generate neo antigens
and those neo antigens are more likely
to be recognized by T cells and to
generate an immune response and it's
been observed that there is a
significant correlation in a variety of
different situations between having a
high chamber mutation burden and having
a positive response to immune checkpoint
inhibitor therapies
the general idea there being that if an
immune response has already been mounted
and suppressed then unleashing it may
lead to good effect good outcomes
so this tumor mutation load assay that
we provide like our other essays it's
part of a streamlined solution it's on a
plastic based with automated library and
template prep on the chef on the Iron
Chef system and sequencing on the gene
Co as five it's a targeted assay that
amplifies up 1.7 mega bases of the
genome it requires two ampliseq tools to
achieve this so at ten milligrams each
that's 20 nanograms of input required
and it's provided like many of our other
applications with an integrated sample
to answer solution that has optimized
and pre-configured bioinformatics
you
so many of the initial studies on tumor
mutation burden focused on use of whole
exome sequencing to make the initial
discoveries in relation to the relevance
of tumor mutation burden that's been
very effective but in terms of broader
app and more routine application whole
exome sequencing is is somewhat
unrealistic for a number of different
reasons the exome sequencing cost is
still quite high relative the cost of
targeted sequencing it has a higher rate
of failure on FFPE samples and it also
of concern to some it pulls along with
it a lot of other irrelevant information
in the form of variants of unknown
significance targeted panels are
typically preferred in clinical settings
also in the early approaches based on
whole exome I need to determine which
variants are somatic variants by also
doing whole exome sequencing of a
matched normal sample so that germline
variants can be identified in the normal
sample and removed to reveal which of
the variants are somatic but
logistically that's often very hard to
put into practice and so a tumor only
approach is is also preferred
so moving on
[Music]
this slide here is showing the results
of some in silico analysis that we did
to demonstrate and convince ourselves
that we didn't need something on the
scale of a whole exome to be able to do
accurate characterization of tumor
mutation load so here are the results
shown of an in silico study using over
21,000 publicly available exons and in
the plot on the Left we're showing on
the x-axis the exome mutation count from
whole exome sequencing and on the y-axis
the mutation count from our 1.7 mega
base tml panel and as you can see here
there's very good correlation between
the two the plot on the left is
summarizing all 21,000 exomes and then
in a series of plots on the right it
shows the same data but just restricted
to subsets of different cancers and so
you can see here you know very good
correlation between the focus panel and
the whole exome sequencing in a range of
different cancers
in this slide we further done
the ability of a smaller targeted panel
to replicate whole exome sequencing
results the slide summarizes data from
three published studies that
investigated genetic correlates to
clinical response to immunotherapies in
non-small-cell lung cancer and in
melanoma the studies showed that
estimates a tumor mutation burden
derived from exome sequencing were
significantly higher and clinical
responders compared to patients that
didn't receive benefit from either
anti ctla4 or anti pd-1 immunotherapy as
you can see in the box plots shown here
for the three different studies we
looked at wizard we observed a similar
pattern of strong differentiation
between the responders and the non
responders when we redid the analysis
restricting attention just to the
regions that we target in the tumor
mutation load assay so in every case the
number of somatic mutations covered by
the assay was significantly higher for
the responders relative to the non
responders and this result to suggests
that the assay is sufficiently large to
support clinical research into the
genetic carlitz associated with response
to the immunotherapies
this slide shows how our assay can
operate without the need for a match
normal sample so after calling variance
in the tumor only sample we implements a
series of filters primarily leveraging
comparisons to public databases of
common variation including you know the
thousand genomes 5000 exomes UCSC common
snips and the exact database and we use
those to remove germline variants the
plot on the Left shows it
before-and-after view of the allele
frequency distribution in a tumor only
sample so on the left is the allele
frequency distribution that we see
before applying filters to remove
germline variants and on the right you
can see the much lower allele frequency
distribution as you would expect from
the somatic only variants the plot on
the right compares the mutation counts
in the tumor only workflow shown on the
y-axis with the mutation counts from a
workflow that compares tumor with its
match normal shown on the x-axis and as
you can see this is very high
correlation between the two approaches
you
at lastly on the tml panel the data
being shown here are from a study done
by Josie Carlos Machado in on padam up
in portugal used a collection of
colorectal samples at colorectal cancer
samples which have been previously
characterized with respect to their
microsatellite instability status and he
profile those same samples with the
tumor mutation load assay and
microsatellite instability is a
biomarker that is known to generally
correlate with tumor mutation load in
colorectal council cancer so we're
pleased to see here the high degree of
differentiation that you see in the box
plots between the mutation count
distributions in the MSI positive and
the MSI negative samples
so lastly I'd like to provide a couple
of examples that show how the four
assays some of the four essays that I've
just gone through in the previous slides
can be used together for the study of
cancer immunity cycle
so the first example is going to involve
comparing the TCR repertoire and gene
expression in the tumor microenvironment
but first before stepping into the
example I wanted to share a study that
we did comparing the repertoire seen in
the tumor microenvironment and that seen
in peripheral blood so in this study we
took RNA from peripheral blood
leukocytes and RNA from a lung tumor in
a single individual and we ran them both
through TCR beta the TCR beta long Reed
assay and compared the repertoires that
we saw with each other so that's what's
shown in the right the comparison
between the repertoires and on the left
we see a summary of what was seen within
each so within the tumor biopsy the
repertoire was much smaller and much
less diverse overall algo clonal
repertoire Shannon diversity of just
under 7 and just under 600 unique T cell
receptor seen by contrast in the blood
we saw over 45,000 unique t-cell
receptors so very diverse and rich
repertoire Shannon diversity close to 14
the plot on the left are on the right
side compares the two with each other
and clearly many of the clones are
unique to the much more diverse
peripheral blood repertoire but a
substantial fraction of the clones that
were found in the tumor microenvironment
were also detected in peripheral blood
so this supports the notion that the
study of peripheral blood can be
informative about the tumor
microenvironment
so moving on to that first study the
question of interest here that we were
looking at was to see if we can identify
immune cell Co infiltrates that
influence t-cell function in the tumor
so just before diving into the data I'd
like to first review the concepts of
evenness and repressive and permissive
tumor micro-environment
so even this is a metric of the
repertoire that we often use this metric
helps to understand if Tisa if there's a
t-cell immune response within a sample
so even as values range from zero to one
one represents a perfectly even
population of t-cell clones for all our
presence at the same frequencies and
that's what you might expect where there
are no clones that are responding to
antigen conversely in the case of a
clone responding to antigen and being
significantly expanded you would expect
to see an uneven repertoire and a much
lower value of evenness so this evenness
metric is useful in the context of the
tumor microenvironment in that we can
look at it to help us understand if the
tumor is repressive or permissive to an
anti tumour t-cell response so in a
repressive tumor microenvironment the
tumor is somehow inhibiting an anti
tumour t-cell response and in this
scenario one would expect to serve high
evenness values following TCR immune
Reptar sequencing by contrast in a
permissive tumor microenvironment the
tumor allows for t-cell expansion and
some anti-tumor activity and in this
scenario one would expect to observe low
evenness values following TCR immune rat
sequencing so we use this to study the
question if you can profile the t-cell
repertoire in the tumor microenvironment
and study it in the context of other co
infiltrates that may influence t-cell
function in the tumor
to that end in this study we
interrogated the tumor microenvironment
of 19 non small cell lung cancer samples
we started with fresh Road fresh frozen
tissue biopsies and we ran them on the
TCR beta long read assay and on the
immune response expression assay so the
violent plot on the left-hand side here
is showing the the evenness across the
different the 19 different samples and
you can see here that most of them had
fairly high evenness values
corresponding with permissive
environments and a small number had very
uneven repertoires to understand why the
t-cell populations are highly even and
why summer are or not we correlated the
t-cell evenness with gene expression
data from the immune response assay and
that's shown in the plot on the right
where we look at the overall correlation
of different categories of genes and
here we observed a very strong negative
correlation between t-cell evenness and
the expression of genes important for
proliferation and we observed a strong
positive correlation between t-cell
evenness and the expression of myeloid
suppressor cell signatures so this
suggests that the mile express ourselves
may be involved in suppression of an
immune response so this is an example
here of how the extent of t-cell
expansion when looked at together with
the levels of repressive Co infiltrates
made together constitute a
multi-dimensional biomarker that
improves prediction of response to
cancer immunity at the immunotherapy
treatment
you
the second example
I'm sorry the slides weren't advancing
there
example that I'm showing here comes from
our collaborators and only seek they've
combined the results from immune
response panel with those of our tumor
mutation load assay and PDL one
immunohistochemistry all run on the same
sample and integrated into a powerful
new predictive model which they've
trademark as the immune report card the
results are extremely exciting in that
the positive predictive value for tumors
with high immune activation scores is
over 90% as is the negative predictive
value for immune and low immune
activation scores so that's what's shown
in the results on the right there where
they did a study on almost 90 different
cancers from a variety of different
tissues and they profile each through
their immune immune report card score to
classify them as being either low
intermediate or high in terms of their
likelihood to respond to checkpoint
inhibitor therapy and then within each
of those categories you can see the
stratification between the responders
and the non responders and as as you
would hope those that were categorized
categorized as high a large fraction of
them so over 90% and were in fact
responders those were categorized as low
a very large fraction of them over 90%
ended up not being responders and then
there's still a population in the middle
so about half of the overall sorry about
25% of the overall samples ended up in
this intermediate category where they
were split about evenly into responders
and non-responders for that certainly
room for future improvements in the
predictive ability to get more
predictions out of that intermediate
category into the high and low but
overall these are very promising results
and omniseek believes that their immune
report card assay can become a standard
for predicting response they're also
working on expanded versions of this
model that factor in
TCR beta repertoire results as well
you
so in summary I've shown you four of the
different solutions that we provide for
the study of immune oncology our TCR
beta long Reed and short Reed assays our
immune response expression Si and our
tumor mutation load assay and have given
some examples of how these can be
combined together to to provide the
basis of multi-dimensional biomarkers so
these are these are some more details
but I've run through these on the
individual assays and then just to
remind you these are all available in
the context of our ion chef and jean
studio s5 systems which have a high
degree of automation which makes them
extremely reproducible the gene studio
s5 itself is designed for scalability
and flexibility so we have multiple
different chips that can be used with a
sequencer to tailor to the level of
sequencing throughput that's necessary
for however many samples and need to be
analyzed and what the read requirements
are on that particular day and the
sequencing one of the strengths of the
sequencer is its speed the sequencing
and the analysis all happen extremely
fast the sequencing itself takes on the
order of two and a half or less hours
and these are provided in the context of
full sample to answer solutions we have
pre-configured and optimized by
informatics to get you all the way from
Apple through to answer and then lastly
I just like to give an advance notice
that we will have some follow-up
presentations to this one where my
colleague dr. Tim Looney will give two
more talks that are going to go into
more detail on some of the assays that I
described here so the first one will
focus on the TCR beta long read assay
and the second will focus on the TCR B
short read assay so those are coming up
on August 16th and on September 12th and
the link shown here
can be used to get into more detail on
that
and lastly all of the work that we that
we've shown here is is really fitting
very well with derma Fisher Scientifics
mission to enable the world that are
enable our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer it's a
mission that we're all very proud of
here
so with that I'd like to close and turn
it over for questions
thank you dr. collie for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the answer question box located on
the far left to your screen well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is how many samples could be
pulled together on five twenty five
thirty and five forty chips
that answer is going to depend on the
assay that you're using so you know
unfortunately this is one of those
answers where it depends you know I've
talked through a range of different
assays in a range of different
applications here and in some of them
it's going to require you know the the
goal of the experiment to be examined to
decide how much throughput is necessary
you know so for example with the TCR
beta sequencing for applications like
minimal receives detection the
sensitivity that you're going for one in
10,000 or 100,000 is going to have a
huge effect on the number of reads that
you're going to need for that so so yeah
I think that that's that's maybe the
short answer and we can perhaps follow
up offline with information with the
full detailed information of what the
multiplex level is on the different ship
types for different kinds of
applications
now dr. Collier our next question is is
a two per question ion reporter software
seems to be the analysis software of
choice is this something that comes with
the system or do we need to purchase it
separately is this a third-party
software so the ion reporter software is
software that we've developed in-house
and you know that the we use it to make
available a series of work for workflows
that are pre-configured and optimized to
the different applications that we
support its software's available for
free in the cloud it's also available
for people who wish to run it locally
it's available in a local server
editions which requires the purchase of
a server from us to run it on and yeah
so it's it's in-house software in terms
of third-party software as I mentioned
during the talk we do also make it
straightforward for people to get data
out of our system so that if they wish
they can also run it through other
third-party packages of their choice
and our next question is will you have
any assays that address b-cell
repertoire
so the assets that we have available so
far for immune repertoire sequencing are
exclusively for t-cells we are
definitely interested in b-cell
repertoire sequencing and while we have
no products available for that today
it's it's something that we may do in
the future
now it looks like we may have had a
little bit of technicality but because
the slides did not advance past slide 31
would you happen to be able to review
slides root excuse me review slides 32
and 33 for us sure
so that was related to the study on
non-small-cell lung cancer where we were
using the immune repertoire that sorry
the TCR be long read assay and the
immune response expression si together
on the non small cell lung cancer
samples so this was I think we got stuck
on on this slide that was just setting
it up in terms of talking about
permissive versus repressive tumor
microenvironment and how they have
different t-cell evenness but the main
result was this one here that is showing
on the left the evenness values from the
repertoires on the 19 different samples
so most of them fairly high evenness and
then the main result is shown in the
correlations on the right which is
showing the correlation between the
t-cell evenness and different expression
signatures shown on the right so the
correlation on the left side of that the
most negative correlation is the one
that shows the negative correlation
between t-cell evenness and
proliferation and the rightmost one is
was the very positive correlation where
even this is highly positively
correlated with the myeloid derived
suppressor cell which is the result
that's you know suggestive here that
it's the my low Drive suppressor cell
that is involved in causing and
suppressing the response and resulting
in an even and thus repressive
environment
then dr. collie it looks like we have
time for one more question is there any
overlap in the content from the aqua
mine TCR beta L long Reed and the aqua
mine TCR beta short read assay
yeah I mean they are essentially both
amplifying up overlapping regions in the
in the t-cell receptor so the long read
assay works only on RNA and it's
amplifying up a longer region that
includes CDR 3 but also CDR 1 & 2
whereas the short read assay is also
operates off of RNA and can also work on
DNA and it amplifies up just CDR 3 so so
the content that both of those panels do
amplify our you know 1 is a subset of
the other
the you know one of the primary uses of
the short read essay is to be able to
use short amplicons which enables it to
be used with FFP samples which are you
know by for by far the most common type
of sample available for clinical
oncology work and the downside of
working with FFPE samples is that the
DNA and RNA are typically very degraded
and so our amplicon based approach needs
to use short amplicons to be compatible
with that pd long applicants would not
work
thank you again dr. collie do you have
any final comments for our audience no
more comments other than just to thank
everyone for their time and interest in
this topic which is one that greatly
excites us so thank you very much and I
wish you a good day we would like to
thank dr. collie for his time today
discussing how the cancer immunity cycle
can be deciphered utilizing the
next-generation sequencing technology we
would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration at the end of
this webinar you will be redirected to
the registration page for our second
webinar in our three-part immuno
oncology series titled advancing
precision immunotherapy through
next-generation sequencing of t-cell
receptor
presented by dr. Timothy Looney this
live webinar is on August 16th at 8 a.m.
Pacific time this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through february of 2019
labyrinth will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event we hope to see you out of
16th until next time goodbye